right and uh liberal right
gives it 1 name is so incredibly Big and dominant
if you now have any feeling in your thunder
social feeling in your thunder
please get up if you just want to live
I mean yes exactly no
but get up and interfere
the 8 hour working day is
don't just fall from the sky
it
women's suffrage is not just out of the blue
falling is a battle for that
by ordinary people who thought
now it is enough
something has to be done and we are going to build up pressure
that really didn't just happen because there
have been parlimentary elections
yes is set up full of pressure on eh
so yes you interfere
that's my biggest
actually my biggest main message